Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
“Chiudere il blindato
delle celle sovraffollate di persone
mi fa tremare la mano”.
Nel mio primo giorno
nel carcere di Marassi,
il 24 giugno del 1991,
un giovane poliziotto in divisa
mi disse questa frase.
E fu un'emozione forte, dura, potente.
Ricordo ancora gli odori nel naso,
e i rumori nelle orecchie:
un vero contatto, credetemi,
da girone infernale.
Io vedevo questi corpi-a-corpi
di detenuti e di poliziotti,
in una giornata dai ritmi ossessivi,
tutti uguali e insensati.
Sveglia; doccia; passeggio;
ozio; ancora passeggio;
chiusura delle celle alle 16;
e ozio fino al mattino seguente.
I detenuti si chiamavano -
quelli più fortunati, che erano aperti –
lavoranti: scopino; spesino;
magazziniere; addetto alla cucina.
I detenuti sono:
aperti o chiusi; trasferiti o liberanti;
o addirittura “SAV”, sorvegliati a vista.
Un mondo che omologava,
un mondo che non rispettava la dignità.
“Una giornata sempre uguale:
lo stesso giorno, moltiplicato per 1095”,
ebbe a scrivere un detenuto
condannato a tre anni.
Questo era il mondo
in cui io avevo impattato.
Ma c'è un articolo
della nostra Costituzione,
che è l'articolo 27, comma terzo,
che dice che
“Le pene non possono consistere
in trattamenti contrari
al senso di umanità
e devono tendere alla
rieducazione ddel condannato”.
E allora, io mi sono chiesta:
che contatto c'era
tra il principio costituzionale,
che avevo sedimentato e studiato
in tanti anni di università,
e quella deprivazione materiale e morale
che si palesava ai miei occhi?
Era lo stesso mondo che avevo studiato?
Ecco: la pena detentiva,
dice la Costituzione,
e dice anche la Legge,
deve conservare intatti tutti i diritti
compatibili con la mancanza di libertà.
E quali diritti vedevo,
e quale dignità del lavoro
di poliziotti che turnavano
in turni massacranti -
8-16, 16-24, 24-8 - in quel girone,
dormendo in caserme fatiscenti
e mangiando in posti orribili?
Allora mi sono detta:
cambio lavoro,
o provo a comprendere
e a cambiare questo sistema?
E cosa ho pensato?
Ho pensato che la legge è chiara,
e dice che la pena
è la mancanza di libertà.
E questa mancanza di libertà
è la pena peggiore che possa capitare,
dopo naturalmente
la soppressione della vita.
Ma all'interno del muro di cinta,
all'interno di quella città fortificata,
forse le giornate potevano
essere vissute in maniera dignitosa.
Forse potevano essere ricche
di opportunità,
pur in una vita limitata.
E allora, pensai che forse bisognava fare
una grande marcia indietro
da parte dell'istituzione totale,
a favore degli abitanti
della città fortificata,
che potevano avere il diritto
di vedere i propri cari
in maniera meno disumana,
di studiare, di fare sport,
di leggere, di lavorare,
di coltivare i propri interessi,
di coltivare la cultura.
Perché, vedete, si può parlare
di cittadinanza attiva anche in carcere.
Perché c'è un altro articolo importante
della Costituzione, l'Articolo 2,
che recita testualmente:
“La Repubblica riconosce e garantisce
i diritti inviolabili dell'uomo
come singolo e nelle formazioni sociali
ove si svolge la sua personalità”.
E chi ha detto che il carcere
non può essere una formazione sociale?
Anzi, dovrebbe esserlo:
perché l'articolo che abbiamo letto prima
parla di obbligo
di rieducazione del condannato.
E dunque,
quando la realtà del nostro Istituto,
degli istituti che ho diretto,
cominciava a somigliare di più
a quello che dicono
le leggi e la Costituzione,
che cosa succedeva?
Succedeva, vedete,
che i detenuti, gli ospiti,
non si sentivano più delle vittime
oppresse da un sistema;
ma trovavano un tempo e uno spazio
per entrare in contatto
profondo con se stessi.
E, badate bene,
anche con l'ombra inquietante
di quello che avevano commesso, del reato,
cosa che non ti è consentita
se il ritmo è assordante,
ossessivo e insensato.
Ma succedeva anche un'altra cosa,
su cui vorrei fermare
la vostra attenzione:
accadeva che più questo carcere
dava spazio agli ospiti,
più le persone che venivano da fuori,
anche i miei amici, mi dicevano:
“Ma allora questo non sembra un carcere!
Ma non è un carcere!”.
Perché questa domanda?
Chiediamocelo.
Forse perché, nel nostro inconscio,
non basta che ci sia
la privazione della libertà.
I detenuti condannati
devono stare un po’ peggio:
devono marcire un po’ in galera,
per usare una frase
che è stata detta recentemente.
Devono stare male,
perché ci hanno fatto male
e devono stare male.
Viceversa, il carcere non è
un posto dove si finisce:
è un posto dove si ricomincia.
Il Cardinal Martini diceva:
“Dopo la sentenza,
comincia un'altra storia”.
E allora, noi abbiamo
immaginato un detenuto
che, metaforicamente,
potesse aprire con una chiave
il portone del proprio carcere
per guadagnare, piano piano,
guidato dagli operatori,
una libertà, che si spera sia definitiva,
in modo responsabile:
con un permesso premio,
poi col lavoro all'esterno,
poi con una semilibertà.
Perché dobbiamo pensare una cosa:
che se escono peggiori,
è peggio per tutti,
per i buoni e per i cattivi,
per i reclusi e per i liberi.
Ma io, oggi, vorrei parlarvi
di un'altra storia,
la storia che oggi
costituisce il mio lavoro,
che è la storia
di chi sconta la pena fuori dal carcere.
Vedete, sono 30.043 i soggetti
che sono condannati
a scontare una pena fuori dal carcere
quando la pena non supera i quattro anni,
contro i 53.509 detenuti.
E com'è la giornata di costoro?
È una giornata fatta di regole,
e una pena che non ha l'afflittività,
che non mortifica, ma che è una sanzione.
Ci sono obblighi di lavoro,
di risarcimento delle vittime,
di giustizia riparativa, di volontariato.
Ci sono divieti, naturalmente,
di frequentare determinati ambienti,
di espatriare;
obblighi di tornare a casa
a una certa ora.
È una pena modellata
sulla storia personale del soggetto,
e sul reato commesso.
Sono 72 gli uffici di probation in Italia
che io coordino come Direttore Generale
dell'Esecuzione Penale,
e prendono in carico i condannati
e li accompagnano
a una libertà definitiva.
Eppure, se ci fate caso,
questa pena scontata sul territorio
è sistematicamente scambiata per:
libertà; ingiustizia;
depenalizzazione; denegata giustizia;
e chi più ne ha, più ne metta.
E perché questo?
Perché, quando noi pensiamo
alla certezza della pena,
pensiamo sempre alla certezza del carcere
fino all'ultimo giorno?
Cerco di dimostrare che la pena,
che viene presa in carico,
oltre che dagli operatori,
anche dallo stesso detenuto,
dallo stesso condannato,
è una pena che responsabilizza.
Il condannato scommette,
insieme agli operatori,
su un futuro di legalità.
E dunque, è una pena
che si basa sulla responsabilità.
Ma c'è di più:
vedete, dal 2014 è possibile, anche,
che gli imputati,
quindi le persone
che sono ancora sotto processo
e non sono state ancora
condannate per una pena,
sempre che non superi i quattro anni,
chiedano al proprio Giudice
che il processo sia sospeso,
e chiedano di lavorare gratuitamente
presso i Comuni, i servizi di biblioteca,
i servizi scolastici, le regioni;
o ancora, presso enti dalla determinata,
importante vocazione sociale:
Legambiente, Croce Rossa, Caritas, FAI.
E questo è un contatto, se vedete,
ancora più sensato e più profondo,
perché è il contatto
con l'Italia migliore.
Se la messa in prova va a buon fine,
se il lavoro di pubblica utilità
svolto gratuitamente
viene svolto correttamente,
il reato si estingue.
Quindi è un ottimo modo di prevenire,
oltre che di deflazionare,
naturalmente, i Tribunali.
Ma noi abbiamo fatto di più:
abbiamo cercato di matchare
il tipo di lavoro che andavano a fare
con il reato di cui sono accusati.
Per esempio, una persona
che è accusata di reati ambientali
va a lavorare a Legambiente,
e così si rende conto di che cos'è,
davvero, la tutela dell'ambiente.
Ecco, questo è il mondo del probation
che volevo raccontarvi.
Il racconto di una pena
svolta con dignità, e con responsabilità,
deve aggiungere un altro tassello,
per essere completa:
quello del rapporto con le vittime.
Vedete, si possono trascorrere
decenni e decenni di reclusione
senza mai mettere a tema la questione
della responsabilità vera verso l'altro.
La responsabilità
verso l'altro prende forma
quando i rei incontrano
i volti delle loro vittime.
La mediazione penale è un percorso
che si può fare, naturalmente,
se gli autori di reato
e se le vittime lo vogliono:
non c'è niente di obbligatorio.
Però è un percorso che,
voi lo capirete bene,
nasce soltanto quando la pena
non mortifica, non annienta,
non annulla la personalità;
ma quando si mette la persona
in condizioni di entrare
in contatto con sé stesso.
Alla mediazione penale, vedete,
non importa il perdono,
non importa la punizione:
importano le conseguenze del reato.
Attraverso la mediazione
si ricuce quella ferita,
che è una ferita che si portano dentro
le vittime e gli autori di reato.
La ferita delle vittime è la ferita
di chi è stato fortemente compromesso
nella propria identità
dall'azione delittuosa,
e lo può restare per tutta la vita;
la ferita dell'autore di reato
è un passato con cui fare i conti.
E questo incontro
può essere anche un incontro -
può essere, perché può darsi
che non vada a buon fine -
però è una grande scommessa,
ed è una scommessa di rigenerazione
anche delle proprie esistenze.
Agnese Moro, la figlia di Aldo Moro,
si è sottoposta, insieme
agli assassini di suo padre,
a un percorso di Restorative Justice,
durato sette anni,
al termine del quale
ha detto queste parole:
“Penso a mio padre con tenerezza,
e senza rimpianti”.
Ecco: allora, concludendo,
una pena gestita con tatto,
scindendo le due parole,
è una pena, prima di tutto,
che lascia integra la dignità dell'uomo,
[e che] senza smettere di essere tale
fa incontrare il condannato
con la comunità dei liberi,
guidato dagli operatori.
E senza smettere di essere tale,
gli fa incontrare,
finalmente, la sua vittima.
Ecco: io sono convinta
che questo è il modo migliore
per abbattere la recidiva,
e costruire sicurezza sociale.